-This is based on real women
who started a choir.
-Yeah.
-And a fair amount of them
were in the film.
-Oh, well, they were sort of
you know, background artists
and stuff.
So they -- So, our director,
Peter Cattaneo,
who directed "The Full Monty,"
he just wanted it to feel,
you know, as real as possible.
And we were filming on actual --
in army barracks, like,
on their bases and stuff.
So we were filming
in their houses,
and, you know, they were,
like I said, extras in scenes.
And their houses were our
green rooms and stuff like that.
So we really got to know them.
It's based on a -- or inspired
by a documentary here called
"The Military Wives Choir,
where they form this choir
while their spouses
were, you know, in Afghanistan
employed in Afghanistan.
And so, you know,
just to try and take their minds
off this hideous situation
they built this choir.
And, I mean, in real life,
it became this huge sensation.
They had a number-one hit,
and there's 75 military wive
choirs all over the world now,
but our film just takes it u
to a point where they --
I don't know
if it's giving it away,
but they have
this big final song.
-And you -- Are you a singer
Was that one of the things
that drew you to the part?
-No, I'm really,
really not a singer.
I mean, I think everyone -
Kristin thought
she was a singer.
That was lovely.
I mean, she was...
She was like, you know,
convinced she has
a wonderful voice.
And she does.
She's got a really strong voice.
But by the end, her parts were
getting smaller and smaller.
But she just...
And me, as well --
No, I mean, I sang --
I was, you know,
educated in a convent school
so you're always in a choir,
because, you know,
when nuns died, you got to -
if you were in the choir,
you got time off school
to go and, you know, sing
at their funerals and stuff,
so that was a good reason
to polish your singing skills.
But apart from that,
I haven't sung.
-You would incentivize
what would happen
if a nun passed away?
-Well, yeah, I mean,
it was just --
God, I've gone really red now.
It was just a bonus.
It was like an added bonus
It's lovely --
It's lovely to sing, Seth.
I mean, seriously.
-Oh, I see. I see.
This is about the -- Yes.
-It is. It is.
-It's a wonderful film.
And I would also be remiss -
I do --
For anyone who's in lockdown -
I know I've said it
to you before --
I think everyone
should watch "Catastrophe.
-Oh, thank you.
-It's a great show
that holds up.
My wife and I just watched
"Normal People,"
which is a very different
Irish romance.
-It's so good, though, isn't it?
-It's really -- It's fantastic
-They love sex. They were having
the best sex I've ever seen.
-It's really good TV sex.
And I don't want to really mak
this all about "Normal People,
but it's great TV sex,
and it's really good
lockdown sex to watch.
-But did you not
feel uncomfortable?
Like, I loved the film --
I loved the TV series.
-Yeah.
-I devoured it.
But I had to fast-forward
teenagers having sex.
And I don't know
whether it's because
I have teenagers myself,
but I couldn't --
I felt like --
I felt dirty watching it.
-Well, see, now,
I think this is very unfair,
because I thought
we both liked this show,
and now you're saying, like,
I can't enjoy
teenagers having sex.
And I think that they're bot
probably in their twenties
in real life.
-I mean, real life, absolutely
-Yeah.
-I'm invested in the story
you know?
-Now you're making it sound like
I had -- Oh, was there a story
We got through it
in like 15 minutes.
We just skipped ahead
to all the teenage sex stuff
-[ Laughs ] I don't think anyone
else had a problem with it
-That's good. But anyways,
a perfect companion piece
is "Catastrophe,"
"Normal People,"
and "Military Wives."
It's so great to see you
as always, Sharon.
-Nice to see you, too.
Thanks a million.
-Great. Be well.